ein paar kilo muss noch weg training in
der schweiz hier im wallis bin ich
aufgewachsen auf 2000 meter höhe
ich sage gerne ich bin ein bergler nur
ich stand auf keinem den berühmten
gipfel in meiner heimat vom bergsteigen
habe ich keine ahnung doch einen großen
wunsch attig werden meiner zehnjährigen
korrespondenten zeit den elbrus in
russland zu besteigen den höchsten
gipfel europas nur zweimal wurde wie das
entweder etwas was man nie weiß oder was
man liest dass mit mit dem mithören
das ist klar ich bin hier ich bin ihr
fünftes und das wahrscheinlich zeigen
wie das geht aber aber der will
ebenso auch deshalb bei der
erstbesteiger des elbrus von 150 jahren
ein walliser war und nun will als auch
ich der anfänger den 5642 meter hohen
vulkan erklimmen
meine russischer bergführer alexej
schuss drauf und mein team erwarten mich
bereits guten tag herzlich
das ist mein schicksal in jedem hemd
lautet erfahrene bergsteiger begleiten
mich auf meinem abenteuer
viktor hat um die 40 m brust
besteigungen in den beinen und auch ein
kamerateam und meine regisseuren sind
berg endpunkt alexej fuß drauf kommt aus
sankt petersburg seit mehr als 25 jahren
führt der menschen aus aller welt auf
die russischen berge sie sprechen auch
französisch ich habe etwas
rückenschmerzen vor zwei tagen war ich
bei einer physiotherapeutin sie hat mir
gesagt ich soll er hier die man den
finden und dran bleiben es gibt hier
einen sehr guten masseur wenn die leute
zu ihm gehen sind sie zufrieden okay
hier im hotel ja hier wie viele kilo die
überflüssigen insgesamt es waren 114 250
wieder 107 ausatmen
entspannen das war sehr entspannen
die arme hinter dem kopf noch einmal
eine art mensch und entspannen
[Musik]
das problem liegt im kreuz bereich aber
die beweglichkeit ist in ordnung
jetzt wurde berg näherkommt wachsen die
zweifel ob die idee wirklich so gut war
am ende meine russland jahre so hoch
hinaus zu wollen
der elbrus befindet sich mitten im
kaukasus er liegt zwischen den beiden
russischen republiken kabardino
balkarien und karatschai tscherkessien
und nah an der grenze zu georgien
[Musik]
erstmals ist auch gut so
mein körper muss sich an die höhe
gewöhnen
der plan eine woche akklimatisation
sonst kann es gefährlich werden sagt mir
alexej das ziel des heutigen tages ist
ein seitental des elbrus allein ist zu
erreichen ist ein abenteuer nicht nur
wegen des museums reifen lifts sondern
auch weil es hier an der grenze zu
georgien überall spezial bewilligungen
braucht im sommer 2008 haben georgien
und russland einen kurzen krieg geführt
die beziehungen sind bis heute
angespannt ich höre hier aber auch sagen
der staatsmacht geht es mehr darum die
lokale muslimische bevölkerung zu
überwachen
als um grenzschutz
[Musik]
filmen an den checkpoints ist verboten
die kontrolle der diversen papiere wird
genau genommen
[Musik]
nach einer langen holper fahrt kommen
wir dann doch noch im bergsteiger can
toyota
das wichtigste ist dass du den pass
dabei ist das ist der wichtigste teil
der ausrüstung für besucher hier
alexej heute morgen eine erste lektion
im steigeisen gehen
wir sehen im uno total im winter ein
beliebtes skigebiet
aber hier unten perfekt genauso
steigeisen sind keine schuhe
obwohl sie haben zehn stehe immer etwas
auseinander
außerdem wird wenn du das nicht tust
dann fällst du dann ging immer abstand
siehst du was du machst
diese müssen ins reich umgekehrt so
umgekehrt wenn du so machst dann rutscht
du kannst dich nicht du bist nicht
stabil nicht zu hoch das ist ziemlich
steil
ja
sehr gut die leute die sterben sie dass
leute wie ich die das erste mal hoch
gehen oder so ohneberg für die mehrheit
kommt ohne bernd schäfer einige haben
zwar etwas erfahren aber nicht für diese
höhe
es kommen viele dinge zusammen das
wetter die große höhe dein kopf
funktioniert nicht so gut wie auf
normalhöhe jetzt wieder unter die top
und dann voll und spalten die kälte für
ihren im nebel
das und die höhenkrankheit sind die
gründe warum der elbrus den menschen zum
verhängnis werden kann erklärt mir
alexej
[Musik]
ich bin froh dass ich nach diesem tag
bereits vertrauen in meinen bergführer
gefasst habe ich würde nicht mit jedem
auf über 5000 meter steigen wollen
[Musik]
wie geht es dir gut ich bin besonders
froh dass es dem rücken gut geht
die schuhe sind in ordnung
machen wir so wenn ich den gipfel nicht
schaffe dann zeigen wir diese szene
nicht ein guter tag ja ein sehr guter
der alkohol tut gut nach der anstrengung
es ist das beste gegen muskelkater um
die muskeln zu reinigen
ich bin chemiker ich kenne alle
geheimnisse enthüllen betonen dass das
die empfehlung eines bett für das ist
normalerweise trinke ich nicht während
der arbeit ich auch nicht wenn ihr kocht
sie uns firmen wir sind doch nicht so
recht gemacht ja schön sei dir und
schmeckt ausgezeichnet
was gibt es heute noch gibt es erst bei
unseren nationalgericht fish mit fleisch
ich werde euch bloß servieren wie ist es
hier mit den ausländern gut sind sie
nicht so sie nicht alles ist in ordnung
wir leben ausländer
ich arbeite seit 25 jahren mit
ausländern
wir verstehen uns gut trotz der
unterschiedlichen sprachen
wir verstehen uns mit händen und füßen
alle fahren zufrieden wieder weg hier
schränkt niemand den anderen ein
hier sind die leute sehr offen und
schließen schnell freundschaft
[Musik]
wie haben die unterkunft trotz
hochsaison fast für uns allein
[Musik]
alexej liebt es hier zu sein weil der
ort ihn an die blütezeit des russischen
bergsports erinnert der chemiker gehört
in den 1980 er jahren zur elite der
sowjetischen kletterer und wurde vom
staat gefördert jetzt fühlte mich in das
camp er möchte mir eine bergsteiger
legende aus alten tagen vorstellen
vielleicht hat der mann ja einen tipp
für mich ich habe schon viele von ihnen
gehört er hört nicht so gut
ach so sie gerade auf dem weg gehen wir
doch in den ausbildungs rom gehen wir
beim gang dahin wird klar das camp hat
seine besten zeiten hinter sich
hier trainierten einst hunderte von
bergsportlern die gewerkschaft bezahlte
nach dem ende der sowjetunion fiel die
unterstützung weg heute sind es nur noch
wenige die sich den aufenthalt hier
leisten können auch wenn die preise
bescheiden sind
[Musik]
ob putin oder putin hilft nicht der ist
dasselbe sportler aber der tourismus
wird doch jetzt gefördert ja aber für
ihn gibt es noch fußball die olympischen
spiele sind jetzt noch die wm
der alpinismus zählt nicht viel zum
glück haben wir den hebel da wollen alle
los das ist der höchste punkt europas
sie ist auch alpinistin nationale
meisterin
sie war der ssc im bergsteigen als jung
war
sie hat viele jahre gearbeitet als
ausbilderin und leite ich helfe sie
hilft mir die liebe zu den bergen hat
die beiden vor 63 jahren
zusammengebracht
seit 50 jahren wohnen sie im sommer in
diesem werk steige kennt
die liebe der russen zum elbrus ist noch
wesentlich eltern und hat eine bewegte
geschichte
[Musik]
1935 eine gruppe soldaten besteigt den
elbrus und verkabelt den weg in die
niederungen des flachland warten die
leute gespannt auf nachrichten vom
gipfel
[Musik]
die junge sowjetunion feiert ihr den
technischen fortschritt auch lenin darf
posthum an der freude teilhaben
[Musik]
und hier unsere gebirgsjäger auf dem
marcel groß gebiet das der elbrus symbol
von russlands macht und stärke ist
bleibt auch der nationalsozialisten
nicht verborgen
eine kompanie von ausgewählten soldaten
einer schwäbisch bayerischen
gebirgsdivision hat es sich zur aufgabe
gemacht auf dem gipfel die 5600 30 meter
hohen bergriesen die reichskriegsflagge
zu setzen
jeder dieser soldaten ist ein
hervorragender bergsteiger weiter
gletscher und schrie felder müssen bei
schneidender kälte überwunden werden
im sommer 1942 gelingt es der wehrmacht
den berg zu erobern
regus ist gezwungen unsere gebirgsjäger
haben damit ein kind porsche und
zugleich alpinistische großes vollbracht
[Applaus]
nur wenige monate später die
rückeroberung durch die sowjets der
kampf in großer höhe fordert viele opfer
aber jetzt stellt ein wichtiges stück
nationaler ehre wieder her
[Musik]
elisabeth schon über afghanistan an der
schwinge brust
[Applaus]
nach dem krieg geht es am elbrus
wesentlich friedlicher zu aber nun wird
der berg definitiv zum nationalheiligtum
[Musik]
1967 zum fünfzigsten jahrestag der
oktoberrevolution sollen es knapp 2500
menschen gewesen sein die am gipfel
standen am gleichen tag
[Musik]
gleichzeitig nimmt der massentourismus
fahrt auf
[Musik]
bahnen hotels und berg unterkünfte
werden gebaut von überall aus dem
ostblock strömen die menschen her
[Musik]
was empfehlen sie mir ich will am
freitag mit alexej da hoch zum ersten
mal
es braucht eine gute erklärt isa zion
sie müssen auf über 4000 meter gehen ein
bisschen trainieren auf den elbrus muss
man laut und runter und grund alles in
einem stück zu machen ist sehr schwierig
erlauben sie mir dass ich ihnen im namen
unseres ausbildungszentrum zurück dauert
dieses abzeichen allein das heißt ihn
ist russlands vielen dank
wir machen es hier fest danke das ist
eine echte motivation
darauf müssen wir einen tee trinken
beim täter handelt es sich dann um einen
50 prozentigen selbst gebrannt dafür mit
einem toast danke euch dass ihr in stara
dazu gekommen seid in unser bergler
holub wir haben herrliche berge
ich hoffe sehr dass es euch gefällt und
dass ihr mit freunden hierher
zurückkommen werde
wir werden euch immer empfangen danke
ich werde meine kinder mitnimmt ist das
wirklich gut für den elbrus das schadet
nicht zu fuß hoch und kopf voran runter
ein bisschen darf man schon es erweitert
die blutgefäße
wir sind in tesco dem zentrum des elbrus
tourismus bei mir zu hause in den
walliser alpen wäre das quasi zermatt
die alten sowjet bauten fallen mir als
erstes ins auge
[Musik]
dann sind da aber auch unübersehbar die
zeichen von aufschwung
[Musik]
auch die moschee ist neu
was ebenfalls auffällt ist auch hier die
militärpräsenz
mein nächster klimatisierungs schritt
steht an
heute geht es auf 3000 meter und ich
werde den elbrus so nahe wie noch nie du
kannst dich umbringt das gibt es doch
nicht
müssen wir weit und hoch das schaffen
wir das schaffen wir
da kriege ich gleich mein ziel heute ist
der werkstatt auf den eine altehrwürdige
bahn fährt dasselbe ziel haben auch
diese grenzschutz soldaten nur fahren
sie nicht zur akklimatisierung auf wie
ich vor wenigen jahren gab es anschläge
in tesco die täter waren islamisten
behauptet moskau hier munkelt man es war
eine abrechnung mit der lokalen
bevölkerung mit den balkan aufgeklärt
wurden die fälle nie eine reisewarnung
jedenfalls besteht noch immer
ich möchte von bahn-chef wissen wie sich
die lage ist sind sie russland
geht's gut wir sind hier der am
nördlichen kaukasus ein heißes gebiet
sind die leute eingerichtet wenn sie
hierher fahren kleiner fürchten sich an
wir haben kann nirgends im kern ist hier
nichts los
aber es gab ja hier 2011 einige
terroranschläge war danach noch etwas
seite war nicht die region um den elbrus
ist politisch hoch komplex das wird mir
auf dieser reise einmal mehr bewusst
[Musik]
schneider
ausgeweitet
frage aller fragen
ich habe früher als schüler bei uns im
dorf jeweils bei den seilbahnen
ausgeholfen
jetzt fühlt es sich bei diesem gefährt
aus den 60er jahren an wie wenn mich die
vergangenheit einholen würde
wir heissen sie wasser und luft
funktioniert funktioniert
1967 ist nicht gefährlich in den 50
jahren ist nie etwas vorgefallen
wie lange arbeiten sie denn schon hier
seit 1978 78 ich war zwei jahre in der
armee
danach bin ich zurück gekommen zeit er
arbeite ich hier können wir dabei sein
wenn sie die bahn einschalten natürlich
[Musik]
ich dürfte nächste woche also kennen die
antwort als nervös gleich fahren wir los
mir dem dorf eine frau gesagt die balkan
würden sich nicht entwickeln wollen
stimmt das eines stimmt so nicht
wir möchten uns entwickeln aber wir
wollen selber investieren service noch
besser machen
die gastfreundschaft liegt uns im blut
das wollen wir bewahren das ist
klassisch nicht das ist unsere tradition
aber wenn jemand von außen mit geld
könnt ihr alles kaufen will
würden die balkanischen sitten und
traditionen verschwinden und auch die
gastfreundschaft die wir noch sehr
fliegen
[Musik]
der bus mit immer höherer so gehören das
bekannte zurück
dazu sagen
[Musik]
in den bergen zählen kameradschaft und
vertrauen hört man immer aber hier oben
gibt es vor der kontrolle durch die
beamten des geheimdienstes kein
entrinnen
doch jetzt will ich mich darauf
konzentrieren was alex amy zum richtigen
atmen in der höhe zu sagen hat
[Musik]
der rhythmus vergehen ist wichtig wurden
auf dieser höhe muss man zweimal so
häufig rat wie man eigentlich möchte
wir laufen ja so
es ist wichtig gerade nicht tief
einzuatmen
bei der als sonst austrocknet hast du
den charakter wegfallen wenn es kalt ist
kann man sich sonst erkälten
und dann erstickt du von mussten das
hilft auf dieser höhe wie ein hund zu
ordnen
mit jedem schritt ein und aus
viereinhalb bis 5000 meter atmen wieso
und den rhythmus zu finden ist singen
gut
das ist ein guter platz ihr scheint wie
für uns gemacht
es gibt ja seit langem diesen streit
befindet sich den elbrus nun in asien
oder in europa nun das ist schwer zu
sagen
soweit ich das verstehe ich bin kein
spezialist bis der elbrus eindeutig in
europa
hier treffen sich die europäische und
die asiatische platte der elbrus
befindet sich 15 kilometer nördlich vom
haupt kranken das heißt er befindet sich
ganz in europa hier ist die politik weil
wenn jemand damit politische probleme
hat mir ist das egal
der blues ist der grund genug sich
selbst
jedes mal wenn ich rausgehe wird es mich
auch frisch
bis jetzt zeigt den elbrus nur aus der
distanz aber heute wage ich mich direkt
an seine flanken
mein nächster klimatisierungs schritt
steht an
aber anders als im norden bringt uns vom
süden her die bahn bis auf 3500 metern
meine route ist die meist begangene und
einfachste wie gemacht für anfänger wie
mich
christoph liese
schau mal sagt mir was du siehst haben
4000 die fast so häufig auf 4000 meter
nein danke
wir wollen nicht schlecht allerdings
habe ich mir die aussicht auf 4000 meter
etwas anders vorgestellt
darf ich mich etwas fragen wo ihr seid
ihr wohl dieser ja das haben wir vor
in diesem outfit fenster ernsthaft wir
versuchen es morgen
wir waren schon auf über 3000 meter wir
hatten ein trainer und jetzt der elbrus
sei die richtige alpinistinnen wir sind
anfängerinnen aber vielversprechend
vorsicht
auch das habe ich nicht erwartet eine
der gefahren am elbrus man kann
überfahren werden die pisten fahrzeuge
und schneemobile fahren mit den
touristen und bergsteigen bis auf über
4500 meter hoch
[Musik]
ich habe akklimatisieren mich zu fuß
weiter und treffe auf gipfelstürmer beim
abstieg
baden sie haben ja heute hat es geklappt
allein mit einem bergführer natürlich
ist es schwierig dieses mal war es etwas
einfacher als vor sieben jahren ich habe
es damals geschafft aber ich weiß nicht
mehr wie geprüft und dann hat mich
runter getragen
jetzt bin ich draufgekommen aber es gab
einen moment da war ich bewusstlos
das hat man mir war schlecht
nach zwei sekunden bin ich wieder
aufgestanden
da oben nach dem sattel es war wie im
ring nach zwei sekunden ausgelaugt aber
dann habe ich den kampf fortgesetzt
heute krank
einerseits bewusstlose und tote
andererseits der bergers halli galli
ich fühle mich hin und her geworfen ich
war auf 4600 meter einer klimatisierung
ist abgeschlossen jetzt ziehen wir ins
hochlager um alles gepäck muss raus
auf dem wege fahrig eine weitere jene
geschichten die nun den elbrus
hervorbringen kann
trainiert hier
das ist ein suchtrupp
was sucht ihr wir waren während des
krieges berg drucken so genannte
edelweiß die sucht leichen überreste
wirklich lässt sich etwas finden
wir finden immer tote soldaten
bei uns in der schweiz haben wir
dasselbe aber keine soldaten sondern er
alpinisten ja die finden wir auch und
wenn finde die er aus dem krieg deutsche
wir finden deutsche wie auch unsere
leute
das hochlage liegt auf 3700 meter höhe
mit schwerem gepäck ist die luft da oben
noch dünner als eh schon
aber auch mal pause
hab
wo sind denn die leute das mixen
zaubermaus hüttenzauber
das war hier das minarett krieg gewesen
[Musik]
ich bin froh wenn es losgeht
der mord ist nicht gerade der wo man
lange ferien machen möchte aber dann
spielt uns das wetter einen streich
[Musik]
an eine besteigung ist im moment nicht
zu denken
ich muss lernen das höhenbergsteigen zu
einem beträchtlichen teil aus warten
bestehen
[Musik]
wir schauen wir gehen können
am samstag ist der wind schwächer
schwelle von 20 am freitag 45 km h auf
dem gipfel
ja aufzeichnungen aus dem totenhaus da
es sich in der bibliothek der parität
größerer spornitz sich bewegen ist
jedoch immer noch besser als herumliegen
aber der hochgebildete verkehr die
ungewissheit und das warten drücken auf
die stimmung
[Musik]
das mit dem auftrag der stau bei uns
doch glaube viele beschränken sich also
ich hoffe wenigen klicks bestellen damit
das geheimnisvollste unser haben es
verlernt wir verschiedene mal oben als
ich meine chance auch für europas nach
russland also freue mich schon freue
mich
[Musik]
dann endlich der abend vor dem gipfel
versuch und die entscheidung
pistenfahrzeug jahren ein
alexej sorgt sich um eine kräfte und er
hat noch andere argumente
[Musik]
diese fahrzeuge sind nun mal hier
wenn wir dann eben gehen atmen wir nur
das benzin vergiften
ich wäre dagegen die pistenraupe extra
zu rufen
aber sie fahren hin und her natürlich
gibt es die ethische frage
vor allem von der südseite her wir
fahren mit dem auto unter bahn dieses
mal mit pistenfahrzeug nächstes mal die
note abgemacht
um drei uhr in der früh geht es los
doch freue mich dass es losgeht endlich
ein festes ritual ga was ist dass die
wir studienplätze schnitt aber das
probieren
[Musik]
jetzt lief
lasst uns losgehen
so ganz berauschend dünkt mich das
wetter immer noch nicht doch der wind
soll im laufe des morgens nachlassen
das beruhigt mich denn es liegen trotz
pistenfahrzeug 1000 höhenmeter von mir
im morgengrauen ist es am kältesten
alexej schätzt es auf minus 15 grad
[Musik]
ach ja schön wenn die festen die tipps
normal ich sehe was hilft
schnell was man will 5000 danke
[Musik]
ist der gipfel das ist der vorgibt der
gipfel ist dahinter
ist das der gipfel da hinten
ganz gut gelöst wird wird
philosophisch erkenntnis kann also sagen
wenn es verarbeitet ist fantastisch
[Musik]
tv geliefert wird
nach sechs stunden ist der gipfel
endlich in reichweite
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie man zum gipfel geht
das ist der gipfel
ich bin hinter dir
massih wassey war
was über
o
[Musik]
schließlich nichts frage
das sieht dass ich mal als abschluss des
25 jahre 50 cent sie zeigten dann dass
sie nicht viel passiert
ich drück sind sie schön sind dann immer
stelle jetzt gar nicht mal hier das dorf
wo ihre hörer sagen herr über das
schicksal einfach darauf schließen dass
ab jetzt rufen an da hilft es sich
einfach die die lite version sind sie
drin ist für kirchner zurück
ich weiß dass von modemacher ohne ohne
selber nicht tragen aber der fall ist
also ist es oben fest dass die gäste
hier mit dem losen sind das ja wie
fröhlich pappigen ist völlig schön dass
ich getroffen hat ist die ganze meldung
jo
aber der schnitt
[Musik]